when I talked about this a little bit up  front but maybe you guys have made  further progress on the show are we  gonna see moments were like you gotta  eat sometime god I like you can't be  running 24 completely like maybe get a  quick nap I'm like what episodes just  like all right this is when he like gets  his laundry done well that's the thing I  mean like in you know and you see it but  the show you know in the pilot at least  you see Eric Carter you know adjusting  to what is domestic life and not being  and being out of the military and um and  and right as things feel right it all  sort of home I mean it's wrong exactly  you know um but it but it's a you know  it's it's fun and it's it's one of those  things I mean I think we were joking  about like what he what he would want to  see like as he's running down which I  understand he's got things to do but  maybe we pull that cliff bar out of whom  keep going I don't know